to the press conference following the
european council also for those who are
joining us remotely
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
we all agree
we must remain vigilant
we are making a lot of progress
and the vaccination
is working very well but at the same
time we are all aware that we face and
we can face not only in europe but also
outside of europe some difficulties that
are related to the vaccination
hesitating
to the to the vaccination hesitancy
and that's why it's also important to
cooperate to coordinate in order to also
progress
uh on this uh
challenge
the support
for the third countries is also a
priority you know that since the very
beginning we have decided to maintain uh
the exportations from europe it's a very
strong choice and you know that you also
work very hard in order to launch with
other partners uh kovacs and to make
sure that
our member states can demonstrate the
european solidarity together with
twisted commission and based on the
decisions that are taken by the
commission
conclusion
[Applause]
foreign
we have discussed this afternoon
migration and you know that migration is
never an easy topic
not in europe but also not outside of
europe but i can tell you that
i had after this general debate
and before we started to discuss the
the the drafting i turned a positive
impression because we had experience in
the past also at the level of european
council we discussed in the past many
times the migration topics and very
often it was a very difficult debate
with many difficulties very difficult to
to to listen to each other to understand
what are the different opinions around
the table and here
we felt i felt
more and more convergence because we
understand that
we have the same goals
we think that it's important to to
address this challenge being more united
being more able to deliver being more
operational and i see two important
dimensions the first one is the external
dimension and the last weeks the last
month maybe just not so visible because
of kravit 19 and other important
challenges we were facing but with the
support of the commission we have worked
very hard in order to clarify what are
the concrete priorities when we see the
external dimension what does it mean
what are the tools that we want to
activate what are the financial means
that we want to mobilize in order to
deliver on this first on this first
important topic the external dimension
and of course it will be needed to
continue
and to maintain our efforts on this
topic point one and point two we know
that the internal dimension is always
something
that could be sensitive but we had the
opportunity to listen to the different
opinions and i as well the impression
without being naive without
underestimating the magnitude of the
difficulties on such a topic but i have
the importance today we have opened a
window of opportunity in order to try in
the next months weeks and months to to
make progress and to deliver and we know
that there are concrete proposals put on
the table for many months by the
commission this is a starting point
different opinions on the starting point
but
i have the impression maybe
there is a a space
for
more political will in order to try to
make more progress on this
important
issue
digitalization
magnitude
thank you mr president madam president
you have the floor yes thank you bar and
um good afternoon
so i would like to start uh with the
discussion we had yesterday on the
energy prices
um the rising energy prices are a real
concern for consumers and business
and we know that this is a global
situation but
it bears lessons that we need to
implement right here in europe too and
that was the discussion all about
first of all in the short term
we need to support vulnerable consumers
and heavily exposed businesses and
member states are already doing it
around about 20 member states have taken
measures or they have announced measures
but this is only for the short term if
you look at the mid and long term we
will work on additional steps
to increase resilience and independence
we have agreed to explore how to
establish a strategic gas reserve
also to explore the possibilities of a
joint procurement
we will intensify our outreach to the
different suppliers also to diversify
the supply we do have
and we have to speed up the work on
interconnections
in parallel we will assess the
functioning of the gas and electricity
market itself and the ets market and we
will report back on that later this year
at the next possibility where the topic
is on the council's agenda
and that leads me to the energy mix of
the future
it's obvious that we need more renewable
and clean energy if you look at the
production price of renewables it has
considerably decreased for solar it is
10 times cheaper today than a decade ago
wind energy very volatile but it is 50
cheaper than it was a decade ago
so that's the way to go they are carbon
free and they are home grown so a lot of
independence is in that
alongside this we need a stable source
nuclear
and during the transition of course
natural gas and this is why as we've
already stated as a commission in april
we will come forward with our taxonomy
proposal the second topic yesterday
evening was indeed
the rule of law
we
had an important discussions on not only
the rule of law but also
the judicial independence
and i welcome that we had that
discussion
the rule of law is at the heart of our
union
we all have a stake in this crucial
issue
because we know that the rule of law
ensures mutual trust
it gives legal certainty throughout the
european union and it gives equality
between member states and for each and
every citizen of the european union
a fundamental pillar of the rule of law
is the judicial independence
and this was the core
of the leaders discussion concerning
poland
we have a long road ahead of us
this road is a combination
of dialogue
legal response
and concrete action to restore the
independence of the judiciary
among other requirements the european
court of justice ruled in july
that the disciplinary regime for judges
had to be overhauled
and unlawfully dismissed judges have to
be reinstated
and we expect
poland to implement this ruling
another topic that we've been discussing
and that was today
is the critical situation in afghanistan
right now afghan people need desperately
food water shelter and access to health
care every second
person in afghanistan is in need of
humanitarian support
and europe is taking a leadership
position here in the global solid
solidarity effort
last week i presented an afghan support
package worth 1 billion euro
and it prioritizes the humanitarian
needs
we need to make sure that displaced
afghans are supported internally
or in the neighboring countries
and this is why we are also supporting
afghanistan's neighborhood under the
support package we have put forward
migration was as sean michel said the
key topic of the discussion today
we are very concerned about the
situation at the borders in with belarus
we consider the behavior of the belarus
government as a hybrid attack
the people used by lukashenko are
victims we must help them
no one's life should be used for
political issues
and this is an instrumentalization of
migration
to pull it put political pressure
on the european union
we will keep up the pressure on the
lukashenko regime
we have already proposed targeted
measures to reverse
visa facilitation for the regime and its
proxies
and we are ready to explore options for
further sanctions not only for
individuals but also for entities or
companies
second we agreed that we need concerted
action
belarus as we're observing now is
looking at opening new routes
it has offered further visa waivers to
additional third countries and we will
continue our engagement with these
countries to limit this state-sponsored
smuggling
we have also discussed the situation in
the mediterranean and the need to
strengthen our cooperation with key
third countries
and all this brings to light indeed the
need for a coherent and effective common
migration and asylum
policy
i reiterated my call to leaders to make
progress on the new pact on migration
and asylum it is there it's on the table
it has to be negotiated it has to be
advanced
so there is really an urge to the
leaders
to move forward and to negotiate that
package thank you so much
thank you madam president we'll first
take
a few questions here in the room loretta
you were first yes please move to the
stand
hi it's uh the rota from polish tv polo
set um i have a question for both of you
if the first time that um the the topic
of rule of law was discussed during the
the eu summit
um but what you are saying um seems to
seems to me that
there has not been much decided uh what
has actually changed after these two
hours discussion with the polish prime
minister you have the same expectations
you had
before um the the subject is not in the
uh in the official conclusions of the
summit why why is that
and what is new after uh talking about
uh rule of law in poland uh for two
hours thank you
first element it's not the first time
that you address rule of law at the
level of the european council i give you
a one one well-known example about one
year ago in july when we agreed on the
net european budget and the mff we spent
a lot of time in order to decide the
conditionality and to strengthen the
european tools which is a demonstration
that
for all of us for the 27 member states
for the european institutions a rule of
law is an important fundamental
principle point one point two with
institutional tools and uh the point of
the commission had the opportunity
yesterday to re-explain to clarify what
are the ongoing procedures what are the
different options what are the different
tools point two point three it doesn't
mean uh that the european council should
paper over uh it's important indeed to
address politically and to have a
political dialogue and that's why i can
i can repeat that we felt yesterday a
strong political message from many
leaders in order also to continue all
the efforts
to continue uh the political debt that
that's also uh needed it's the level of
the council and the european uh council
because there is one goal uh this is uh
to listen to each other to understand
what are the exact problems to be
precise to avoid the ambiguities in
order to deliver solutions this should
be our goal it's not enough just to
observe that there would be irritations
on different sites around the table
what's important for us collectively for
this european project this is the
ability to deliver and to make sure that
we'll be able to find solutions this
must be our common goal
yes
if we look at the timelines
there has been the ruling of the
european court of justice
concerning the disciplinary chamber
the disciplinary regime
and
this is a recent ruling and this has to
be followed by the polish government
um otherwise the european court of
justice will take
further steps and then there's a
parallel
process
there has been recently the ruling of
the constitutional tribunal
concerning or challenging
for example articles in our treaties
this ruling is
a fundamental change
and it is
relatively fresh
new
so we are right now assessing it and two
days ago or three days ago now i have
laid down in the european parliament
detailed what the different options are
to have a legal response of course
accompanied by dialogue and hopefully
followed by concrete actions of the
polish government
and we are at the beginning of this
process now so
right here i think it was very important
that the leaders discussed that topic
because we all have to take our
responsibility in that matter
thank you next question is for eriny
please the greek public tv and athens
news agency according to the conclusions
of migration quote they remains
determined to ensure effective control
of its external borders unquote how he
is going to do so since migration has
been turned to a much more complex issue
that affects different parts of eu with
different needs for example poland and
lithuania and latvia from the one part
and on the other side part cyprus and
greece thank you
now this is true there are different
situations and it's important to to to
be able to take into account all the
specificities and all the concrete
situations that you are that you are
facing this one first point one certain
point uh and this was set by
ursula
it is very clear that we collectively we
condemn
the use by third countries of migration
irregular migration as hybrid threats
against some of the member states and
against the eu this important an
important basic principle and based on
that we understand it's important to to
strengthen
our tools in order to to control our
external borders and we decided to
propose to the to the commission uh to
uh uh
look at different options uh in order to
to to strengthen the country the
concrete support that we can deliver
to the countries when they are at the
front line when they are protecting the
external borders and with a very good
debate on that because we understood
very well that there is a legal
framework this is the basis and we are
ready to assess if it's needed to change
or not maybe it's not needed this uh
legal framework and also we will take
into account the possible proposals and
concrete measures that the commission
will put
on the table based on the assessments
that will be made but we understand the
sense of urgency when it's in a very
sense of urgency we understand that
it's very important to be to be able to
act as strictly as possible and that's
why you understood even if these are
difficult debate this is a difficult
situation in many countries we had the
impression
that
there is a political window of
opportunity in order to be more
more
permit it politically and in order to to
negotiate and to try to find the german
agreement because it was very clear for
many colleagues uh uh they were very
clear that we must be united when we are
not united we are weaker
and if we are united we are able to
overcome
the difficulties
yes the
you were mentioning a few of our member
states indeed
the commission has along the course
always supported these member states and
will of course support them in this
critical situation at their borders
and there are different approaches uh as
you know uh commissioner ilva johansson
and vice president margaret tiskinas
have visited several times these member
states um really to have an own
impression on how to help we sent
frontex
iazo
the agency to support the management at
the border and of course there is
financial support for better border
management so this is the very practical
work on the ground that is ongoing
and then indeed there was an agreement
which is also found in the conclusions
that
we will
look at the necessary
legal measures to improve the situation
one is for example that we are looking
into the schengen border code that will
be on the table anyhow as a new proposal
but there include provisions concerning
this instrumentalization
of migration
state sponsored smuggling that we see at
the moment being and of course there is
the new pact on migration and asylum
this is the most important legal
framework that we should move on and
work with
griselda
[Music]
electricity
[Music]
there was a lot of support for
the toolbox and the communication
so for the short term indeed there is
also overwhelming agreement among the
member states that in the short term
it is necessary in those countries who
have
had these problems to
support
the vulnerable households and
the
mostly affected businesses
and we should not forget that
approximately
35 to 40 percent of the gas electricity
price
is taxes and levees
and therefore
many member states
have taken this
as a possibility either to take the
revenues and to subsidize or to reduce
taxes and levies
to take off pressure from the
electricity price and on top
the member states have 10 billion more
as revenues from the emission trading
system
they are also able to invest in
supporting the vulnerable households and
the businesses at risk
that is the short term
and then indeed we had a very good uh
discussion on looking into
is it good and necessary over time to
have a strategic common gas reserve
so not as today that it is fragmented
and not very strategically applied
second to explore at least the
possibility among those voluntarily who
wanted
to have joint procurement over time
and then indeed the question is looking
at the electricity market as you know
today it is organized that we have all
the different energy sources from
renewable to nuclear to fossil fuel
all together in one price electricity
and
coupled with the gas price that is at
the moment being driving up the
electricity prices
and the question is
um is this combination still the right
one for the future or do we have to
adapt
because renewables and nuclear are
homegrown so we are independent
while we import 90
of the gas we use
acer
has the task to
put up a study
with first results mid-november
so that we can report to
the european council then in december
and
indeed
asthma that's another
agency
or authority will look into the gas
market specifically and the ets market
specifically to have a look whether
there are any kind of speculations we do
not have any evidence so far or not
thank you madam president i'll take a
question remotely as well patrizia
antonini
from ansa thank you thank you for the
vlog
good afternoon i have a couple of
questions and first one is about
migration
um
i hear there was a discussion on barbed
wires and buyers at the
external borders
financed by
the
so i would like um to know what the
committee the president the commission
answered to this request
i also
would like
to understand whether you think
that after last night's discussion there
is a clear-cut support of the member
states
for an action like article 7 or
on the triggering of the
of the conditionality or on the eu
budget and
thank you uh the last question is with
the article seven uh rule of thumb
and the condition of the first question
the article seven or the conditionality
mechanisms
yeah this one i got because sorry that
we're chilling here but um i had a
problem with uh
understanding the second question
should i should i yeah indeed the first
question was for me absolutely um yes
there was a discussion and as you know
there is funding of
border management by
the european budget
and
of course
not only equipment or
partly personnel
but also or the electronics that are
necessary but also so-called
infrastructure
and indeed there was
a discussion on the so-called physical
infrastructure and i was very clear that
there is a long-standing comma
in the commission and with the european
parliament that there will be no funding
of barbed wire and walls
and your second question uh
was
if it goes uh on on the question of
conditionality mechanism
here we also have a very clear
setting
um the conditionality mechanism uh we
need to develop the guidelines we're on
the process to develop the guidelines
indeed at the in parallel the european
court of justice has to judge on
a request from hungary and poland
whether this
uh conditionality mechanism is legally
sound i put it in my words
um so we will look at the result of this
judgment to include it and possible
guidelines as we have discussed in the
council and as i've laid down in the
european parliament
no case is lost since january because of
course we gather all the necessary
information
no measures will be taken
before the ruling but of course we can
send letters uh ask for information or
questions that are necessary to be asked
so that is the setting of the
conditionality mechanism i hope i
answered the question because i only got
half of it
thank you
this concludes our press conference for
today thank you for joining us also
remotely conclusions have been published
on our council website thank you for
joining us
[Music]
you